Some detail on bounding volume hierarchy.
So I mean you,
you take the object, say the
triangles and group them all together.
I mean there are a lot of ways to do that.
This is a combinatorial explosion.
So you cannot just say test
each possibility and check
which is the best one.
So usually this is seen dependent
so you don't know him beforehand,
which bonding volume hierarchy would
give you the best performance because um,
it could be that through
the light propagation light,
very Seldomly enters say one half of the
room because there is a wall with only
a small home.
If you do not know that,
then you would read both rooms with the
same priority and put them very high up
in the tree hierarchy.
But if light only travels very
Seldomly to half of the room,
then you could make one huge node for
only half of the room and spend all your
detail on the thing where
actually something happens.
So the seam usually dictates
what kind of hierarchies optimal.
But this is,
this doesn't make too much sense to take
this into account because if you have
to run the light simulation to know what
is the most optimal spacial hierarchy,
then you have done to
lie to relational ready.
So you need to use some kind of heuristic
that works for general scenes and
build a hierarchy that
optimizes this holistic.
And the most popular one is the
surface area of your Ristick.
We are,
you compute a cost for the whole
hierarchy and try to find the one with the
lowest cost. And here, just
to quickly show the formula,
you can read this in detail
in the references I provide
on the last slide of the
lecture.
But here you sum up two components.
So the costs of the inner nodes of the
trees and the costs of the leaf nodes,
because as we already know the object,
so the triangles are in
the leaf note of the tree.
So all the intermediate nodes
are just different groupings,
so from fine to coarse,
but they do not contain content.
So they just say,
if I hit a bounding box
of some intermediate node,
then it tells me here my neck,
my next level are these two
bounding boxes. Continue with them.
Then you check the next two bounding
boxes in this volume and continue
recursively until you hit all the
leaf nodes that are appropriate.
So that lie along Uri and the costs.
So there is a cost associated with getting
from one bounding box to the bounding
boxes that lie emit and
the cost of the leaf nodes,
which are uh,
also they intersect shoe costs
of the triangles themselves.
So see inner in this
formula is the cost of um,
checking,
which I'm bounding boxes are appropriate
for continuing through the tree.
And the cost for the leaf
node is the same for it.
That tn is the cost for
the triangle intersections.
And now the heuristic enters
via the surface areas of
objects because their main
assumption in this heuristic is that
you have that race lie randomly in your
scene. So you don't, you don't
know him beforehand in which,
uh, directional light will
travel. So you're just as humor,
random rate distribution.
And then you check how profitable
is it that I hit certain objects.
So objects with a small
surface area are less probable,
larger triangles are more profitable.
And what you want to do is that you um,
give very good groupings,
the groupings that um,
that have a high chance that you actually
hit something in them or that you can
exclude a lot of this and this is here
are shown as a ratio of the surface area.
So [inaudible] is the surface area
of note and this is the volume of the
bounding box which has a certain surface
and it's also dictates how probable is
it that I hit this bounding box.
And then you have the
surface area of the root.
So the level above,
so I have my own bounding box
at a certain level of the tree.
And my route that contains me is a
larger bounding box that at least as the
extent of my current one.
But what do you want to do is that you
want to minimize this cost so that you
want to have a large surface area of the
mood but a small surface area of your
current bounding box.
Because this means that you can
exclude a lot of volume in the space.
So if you're going to a huge,
um,
bounding box and you want to
decide where do I have to continue,
then the smaller the continuation
is the more descriptive it is,
where the scene content is.
The same is done for the file,
for the final leaf nodes
where the triangles are.
And now you try to build a whole
hierarchy that optimizes this coast.
So this is not that you can decide at
every level or at every level you decide
what is the best ratio
here that I can achieve.
And then this gives you how
you're grouping has to be done.
Um,
they are different heuristics in the
recent literature that take some more
information of the scene into
account. So, for example,
the surface area heuristic,
the only assumes random rate distribution
in the scene but also assumes that
they are infinitely long so that they
just travel through the whole scene and
the not to block belt checks.
This is taken into account with more
sophisticated to restricts and um,
there are references on this
and
so
yup.
I haven't done handed larger yes.
Can Be larger than its roof because
the two objects move apart from
hell,
um, that you have to account for.
So, so you would have to update,
you would have to propagate this
information up the tree otherwise, um,
it would fade so to say, because
you, if you do not treat the root no.
Yeah, I mean this, you
have to propagate up but
it's the way of the propagation is clear.
So it's just the grouping
upwards till your have contained,
even with the dynamic
update what's happening.
But with Katie trees,
this is not too easy because
the space itself is divided.
So you have to somehow determine where
is the object moving to in which other
part of the tree,
which is not simple because it could be
that it moves into another leaf node,
but the lymph node could be um,
split already at the very
top level of the tree.
So to find the other leaf node,
well Katie three of check moves into,
you have to go up and down the whole tree.
So this is much more costly,
much more complicated here.
You're just propagated
upwards till it's okay.
Um, so I mean, um,
the surface area of your Ristick
is just that the heuristic,
but it's still expensive to
compute the optimal three for that.
So there is not necessarily unique
solution with the minimal surface area
humoristic but there is one
and since this is expensive,
there are also methods how to approximate.
So not to develop a hierarchy
with the optimal cost,
but with one that's good
enough for the purpose.
And usually this is a trade off.
So the more time you invest to
build your spacial hierarchy,
they're better.
It's quality gates and in turn,
the more efficient delight simulations.
So if you don't spend a lot of
time to build your hierarchy,
you have bad quality,
inefficient rate traversal during
the global illumination simulation.
So you are actual rendering takes long.
But if you spent more time
on the hierarchy, then um,
it has better properties
for a propagation.
So your light lighting simulation
is more efficient and it's faster,
but you see that there is
some kind of trade off.
So I mean if I end,
usually this is encoded
and or start again.
Um,
usually it depends on how
complex your light simulation is.
So if I want to trace say 1000 raise,
then the cost of this is very,
very low.
So I just need a,
I can live with a very,
um,
approximated hierarchy.
So the hierarchy quality can be very bad,
but because I shoot so less raise,
I will not feel the difference too much.
But if a shoot, um, break
counts in the billions,
then even a small increase in,
um,
in optimality of the hierarchy,
we'll give you significant
gains in your rendering time.
So what you see here in this graph,
this I just showed that you get a
feeling what are different methods?
They are a,
I put the reference to the actual math
to the actual paper where this is from
right next to it.
So what do you see here are different
methods on how to generate bounding volume
hierarchies with the
surface area heuristic.
So as you see the Blue Line,
the SPV h
okay.
Um,
has very low call or um,
start again.
So what you'll see here is on the x axis,
the number of rays that you will
shoot in your light thing simulation.
So that means that the
more you go to the right,
the more complex the light simulation is,
the more quality you won't
have the final rendering,
the deeper you go into
refraction and reflection levels,
things like that.
MMM.
On the other hand,
on the y axis,
you see how many race delighting
simulation can trays per second.
So that means that the higher you go up,
the y exists,
the faster your lighting simulations,
and now you have to find some trade off.
So SBV age constructs very good.
Spacial hierarchies,
but it's also very slow.
That means that for,
um,
for a lightning simulation that
only use a few million raise,
the performance is very bad because most
of the time is taken to build a spacial
hierarchy.
So for SPD age,
it takes longer to build the hierarchy
then due to the actual rendering,
which doesn't make too much sense.
But if you go into the
indoor one territories for
computing your final image,
then it starts to pay off
because you have a very, uh,
high performance.
So you can trace in this example on the,
we are 400 million raised per second,
um,
[inaudible] BVH a HL BVH on
the other hand is a method to,
um, quickly get a spacial
hierarchy that's not very optimal.
So you see that for, um, scenes
with only a few million race,
you already get close to
the final performance.
So 200,
a million raise per second,
and you are much faster than Spv h here,
but the mores you shoot,
the more you're hurt by the missing
optimality of your hierarchy.
So that means that there is some kind
of sweet spot around 10 Kiko race where
SPV age gets actually better
then
Hrl,
PVH.
And in this paper they propose another
method that is faster to construct.
So you see it in the green belt,
that line.
So you're quickly, uh, it alright.
It gives a significant performance
increase. Man's even for a smaller,
uh,
simulation.
So already at hundred million race
you are better than HL and you'll get,
but you get quickly close to
their performance of SPV age.
So this is in this paper,
this shows that, yeah,
they found a very good intermediate
method that's only a bit less or the mall
then the, uh, state of the art before.
So I advise you to look into this paper.
You see a lot of interesting things there.
So how to port PVH
construction on the cheap view,
parallelization issues
and other smart tweets.
So, uh, um, I give you the
literature. So in Pvr, tea,
it's the chapter four.
And since this is inherently
a geometrical problem,
so you want to know where
our triangles in the scene.
The same hierarchies can also be used
for collision detection because for
collision detection, if you want to
know cook two objects, uh, collide,
then you have to be
spatial near to each other.
So if I know that they are
far apart already in the, uh,
through the bounding boxes off the tree,
then I can ignore this and not compute
the exact intersection between them and
are then there are several papers here.
So the work of [inaudible] more or less
started this whole business and his
thesis.
And then I also give some reason papers
that usually look into how to do this
fast and the cheap view. So this is
more or less the current trend now, um,
there are also upcoming
works to do the same on, um,
this intro, many core
architecture. So the [inaudible].
Okay,
good. This concludes the
first part of this lecture.
Are there any questions?
Yeah.
If not, then I continue with
something completely different. Now.
I mean this is a very technical topic.
If you want to implement it.
Then you have to look into the papers
anyhow because I cannot lay out here all
day issues with coding.
I mean it would be super boring.
And on the other hands it's
okay
also.
Um,
the surface area heuristic in
itself has proved worth food or um,
but I mean did they are a
lot of different approaches.
So approximation of this small part
approximation of this small part.
So there are many papers that focus
different partial problems in the whole,
in the whole research problem.
So going through a lot of later Chinese
also suboptimal because due to the
rapidly increasing hardware capabilities,
the tunnel was also quite fast.
So things that were super smart,
um,
approaches say four years ago to the
carpet anymore because cheap now have
completely different functionality and
can do certain aspects more efficiently.
So this is a rapidly developing,
uh,
topic since yeah, years old, ready?
So if you want to implement it,
have a look at the current literature,
Sarah, if you standard papers like
the one of the, of Ingo light,
which have lasting contributions,
but mostly in between our
small optimizations that
are focused on things that
are perhaps not relevant,
limited
anymore. Okay, good. That's for this.